now in last week supermarkets have
warned that could be price rises and
food shortages if we leave the EU
without a deal but what's the reality
let's try and find out joining us now
from her farm just outside Salisbury is
the president of the National Farmers
Union minute batter's thank you very
much for being with us
now I'm keen to talk to you first of all
about the impact of No Deal because it
does feel like it's a very real
possibility one member of the cabinet
described it to me as about 50/50 what
do you think the impact of a No Deal
brexit would be well the No Deal aspect
for my sector Sophie is absolutely huge
you know agriculture is very reliant on
it sort of critical dependencies if you
like 95 percent of our animal medicines
and vaccines are currently made in the
EU
chemicals fertilizers you know it's been
a vital route if you like but but the
real aspect in all of this and why we
believe long-term to crash out without a
deal is so bad not just for our sector
but for food in general
you've been talking about food inflation
and government is clear it doesn't want
to see a rise of more than 5% and so
it's prepared to allow food to come in
here without any tariffs on it for
animal and animal products farmers would
face an immediate trade embargo we'd be
on third country most favored nation
status on the 30th of March potentially
carved out of the market for six months
organics carved out for nine months or
longer and then of course when we regain
market access we face the high tariff
wall of the EU and it's clear that
government intends to impose its own
tariffs or potentially no tariff wall on
food imports it can't just do that for
the EU has to do it for the rest of the
world so we'd be subsumed by cheap
imports and we know that British
consumers really value our high
standards of animal welfare
environmental protection and above all
else food safety so this is huge for
every single person and I think it's
really not understood actually what No
Deal means we often take questions from
viewers and have to say that when I said
that you were coming on the show we've
got a lot of questions in it's clearly a
subject matter that people are quite
concerned about I've just got one
question here from a man called
Tim Kerby and he wants to ask about what
happens if there are problems at the
borders in the event if a No Deal breaks
say he says what in season foods can
Britons farmers provide immediately and
can they supply of sufficient amounts of
it to feed the population well at
certain times of year yes absolutely we
can and certainly post per exit and teas
now we could have been producing much
more of our fruit and veg at home but of
course you know we've been very reliant
on people choosing to come here seasonal
workers coming here we've been the
preferred destination for people to come
and pick fruit and veg that is all now
put massively in jeopardy and at this
time of year I was with River food
organics in the week and guy Watson
telling me that they are totally reliant
on being able to bring in broccoli and
many other things at this time of year
from Spain so you know you can see by my
farm at the moment you know we've got a
really heavy frost it's minus seven
today a snow covering of course in the
spring summer autumn yes we can produce
a lot more but at this time of year it's
not a great time of year we're into
really the root vegetables leeks
Brussels sprouts people have got used to
a wide variety really having anything
they want at any time of year
seasonality now for consumers is really
sort of forgotten passed one way of
forcing it to be a Brussels Frances
phase and if Britain was self-sufficient
when will we run out of food well look
we produce approximately 60% of the food
that we consume here in the UK we have a
brilliant climate for growing food we
are you know the second largest producer
sheet meat in the world second to new
zealand so you know we are
self-sufficient in areas particularly
liquid milk the dairy industry you can't
import liquid milk of course but i think
food has been taken for granted for far
far too long and if you look at the role
of pharmacists so the little red tractor
logo that shows with the Union Jack that
it's been produced and reared in the UK
and many other assurance schemes like
the leaf mark RSPCA organic certified
what I said about this tariff situation
and bring
cheap imports in this is the key
question because it would undermine
British production
we are the third cheapest producer of
food in the world so the people that say
this is about cheaper food brexit
actually consumers in this country are
getting a great deal already food is
incredibly cheap many would say far too
cheap in the UK with British farmers and
growers taking less than 6% out of that
value so I really hope that food can
rise up the political agenda it's
absolutely Savage for us and No Deal I
cannot imagine how bad it would look
because we'd see a long-term future of
just bringing cheap imports in and
whenever I raised this with Liam Fox or
Michael Gove or the Prime Minister you
know there are no plans at the moment
we've said you know we want this put in
writing on our high standards of welfare
and environmental protection they
haven't put it in writing yet and we
continue to ask and it's a question that
absolutely must be answered before we
leave on the 29th of March that's
interesting so what have those people
said what's the prime minister said to
you what's the in Fox said to you in
those meetings what haven't they said
well we've had a lot of warm words on
this that you know we would lot look to
lower our standards we would not look to
bring food in that is produced to lower
standards but ultimately if we are going
to leave in an orderly way with a deal
if we are going to negotiate free trade
agreements across the world then this
has to be put in writing it has to be
legislated on and we have asked for
bringing a uk-wide group together to
agree what we would want on animal
welfare environmental protection and
food safety a black and white policy
statement and this is not about farmers
this is about consumers 66 million
consumers across the UK that really
value the standards of production we
want it put in writing and it still
hasn't been put in writing when we have
eight weeks to go
it is really simply not good enough you
paint quite a consoling picture saying
that knowdo will be savaged for the
industry and at the same time a lot of
farmers voted to leave the EU many of
them because they don't much like the
Common Agricultural Policy many of them
because they feel that the current
subsidies regime is unfair so are some
positives from
a brexit I mean could we start buying
more locally and actually valuing our
own produce a bit more I think if
nothing else at this moment government
understands agriculture and the food
system far better than it did I mean
that is a concern in itself and yes if
we leave in an orderly manner if we are
prepared to have agriculture as part of
those free trade agreements and not
sacrificed I mean just to put it into
context the CETA deal which is the
Canadian trade deal with the European
Union that took over ten years to
achieve and in the end it was brought to
a standstill by three Belgian dairy
farmers agriculture food is always the
last chapter in any trade deal to be
agreed and my huge worry is that we are
an economy now based on services and
financial services goods is only 20% of
the economy and although food and
farming is the largest and indeed only
remaining primary manufacturing sector
it has to feature in these free trade
agreements and we're just not getting
the assurance that we would like to have
now we're almost that time but there is
one question I really want to ask you
before I let you go inside and warm up
feel it's quite snowy where you are
you're the first ever female president
of the nfu and farming isn't
traditionally seen as you know a woman's
job if you read books to kids it's all
about the farmer and his wife so I just
wanted to ask you if you've experienced
much sexism on your way to the top no
not at all I mean it's a bizarre concept
really because I think of all industries
women have always been involved very
much partnership businesses here in the
UK we're all about family farming
businesses so it's generally a family
running that business women at the
backbone of those businesses and I guess
success for me will be when being a
woman isn't newsworthy oh very good
oh very good on so hopefully one point I
went out to be asking these questions
and thank you very much for coming on
the show today is appreciated thanks so
much